as abortion becomes a central issue
as it usually is but even more so this
year in the presidential campaign
because of the supreme court seat and
the glorious acb
amy coney barrett and roe versus wade
there's a movie that just came out that
is the most
pro-abortion propaganda movie i think
ever made uh it's called unpregnant
get it it's like the answer to unplanned
which was a movie about how great life
is you know this is unpregnant
and it is an all-out pro-abortion
movie that unfortunately my producers
made me watch i had to watch it i sat
through
every second of this trash
just to give you a sense a gist of the
movie it's basically 90 minutes of this
i'm pregnant hell yeah
yeah i'm pregnant and i'm getting an
we're abortion pregnant
and we are precious that's it
it's that for 90 minutes it's a
it's a buddy teenage movie a buddy road
trip movie
about the one girl that blonde girl who
is
a sociopathic narcissist and then the
other girl who is a lesbian with daddy
issues
and they go on this road trip out of
state to
kill the blonde girl's child they have
to go out of state
because it's not even a movie about
whether or not we should have abortion
it's a movie about whether or not we
should have underage abortion
and it's actually not even a movie about
that it's a movie about whether or not
we should have
underage abortion without parental
notice
so you're saying that girls who are i
don't know 13 14 15 16 17
should be able to get abortions without
telling their parents now just
practically how does underage abortion
work what is it used for
it's often used in sex trafficking
because then
if you've got underage girls who are
having sex with men and then get
pregnant you can go
you know kill the baby take care of the
pregnancy and no one has to know it is
used
by i mean truly the worst people the
most wicked evil people in the face of
the earth to do horrible things
often abusing children that is the topic
that this movie takes as this wonderful
thing that they're gonna support
so they go on this trip and it's got the
kind of tone
of a fun little teenage movie but the
punchline is always
this awful thing where you you know the
guy and the girl don't get together
they split up the they don't end up
happily ever after
they they go apart uh you don't end up
with a child in a family you kill your
child and you completely
take out the possibility of having a
family the girl finds out that she's
pregnant at the first scene of the movie
and usually in this kind of thing what
would you expect you'd expect the
the boyfriend who knocked her up to be
really awful and he's abusive and he's
terrible
what's amazing about this movie though
is he's not he's a
nice enough guy who tries to do the
right thing
and when she tells him that she's
pregnant he doesn't yell at her or say
go get an abortion or something
he proposes marriage i'm pregnant
i i mean i i know what i want to do and
i have a plan i could just really use
your help with
some what's happening right now
you marry me would you marry me that's a
great thing to do that's the right thing
to do because what she's saying is
i mean as always happens with feminism
they just try to flip
men and women so they try to make women
out to be men and say the male values
are the only things they should aspire
to
and that you know they make these men
want the things that women traditionally
want so she's saying yeah i want to get
an abortion i want to kill this kid
and then he proposes marriage and you
know what she does she takes his wedding
ring
and pawns it so that she can get money
to
kill his baby his child
as if he has no say in this at all
the kid's his right it's his kid no say
at all so they don't present
a particularly flattering image of this
gal until you realize that they're
inverting everything one of the reasons
that this movie doesn't work very well
is because they don't understand their
subject they don't understand
any of the subjects that they're
touching on you know going through all
of it
one thing that strikes me is that it
it's just a bad movie and listen i've
seen a ton of bad movies i've been in a
few bad movies
so i i know the the qualities of a bad
movie it's a
very weak is just a matter of content i
had this i had to invest my time in this
horrible
garbage movie however if you choose to
invest your time in the stock market
i would highly recommend phenom group
how's that for a segway that was just
phenomenal you can invest in trade like
a pro with phenom group and their
premium membership tier
gets you exclusive daily trade signals
in-depth market analysis
including stocks currencies futures and
options what i would personally
recommend
is the mastermind options tier which
gets you everything plus a live daily
trade room that follows published trades
and exclusive option trades
right now you should head on over there
you should not go watch this dumb movie
but you should go go head on over there
if you're interested
in investing go to phenomgroup.com and
use coupon code
dailywire at checkout for 20 off
the first two months that is coupon code
wire at checkout at phenom group
f-i-n-o-m
for 20 off or just click on the link in
the bio
educate yourself on it it's a great way
to get into investing so go check that
out right now
unfortunately i will have to continue
checking out this stupid movie
the issue is they don't understand the
things that they're talking about
so the heroes in the movie are the
people who are
killing babies professionally like the
abortionists and
the girls who are now being encouraged
to go get abortions without their
parents
forget consent not even the parents
notification and
to go kill these children without their
their the fathers of those children
having anything that they can possibly
say about i mean
those are the heroes and then the
villains are you can expect
christians parents there's
one place where a kind of conservative
he's more like a kooky libertarian guy
is actually a hero they find this guy
out in the middle of nowhere and they
need him
to use his limousine company to drive
them the rest of the way
out of state to go get this underage
abortion they try to make
a conservative or a libertarian argument
for abortion and it just totally falls
flat nothing about it rings realistic
the law there won't let me get uh
one without my parents knowing so we had
to go all the way to new mexico
big government thinking they can tell
people what they can and cannot do with
their bodies it makes me sick
oh and there's the big surprise right is
this guy who they think is going to be
really against it he's
he's for abortion because he's a he's a
true conservative he's a
he's a coherent libertarian who believes
that people should control their own
buys and of course
the conservative position and the
libertarian position on abortion is
pro-life because from the conservative
perspective
there's nothing very conservative about
killing your future killing your
children
and uh there's nothing particularly
moral about that or it's obvious obvious
violation of the moral order but even
for libertarians who
who ground a lot of their political
views in the non-aggression principle
it's an obvious violation of the
non-aggression principle because you're
you're killing a
living human being many of the most
prominent libertarians around for the
past uh however
however long you know and all in recent
memory have been pro-life and that's why
so
they don't understand the political
dynamic here they're just kind of
reciting
what some stupid you know freshman year
leftist says they say oh you got it
you've got to be totally
consistent you're for small government
until it's about women's bodies it's
like no i'm also in favor of laws
against murder right that's
i don't think that's a government
overreach and it's the for the same
reason that i would oppose abortion
because you're taking the life of
another human being so you get that
wrong they totally misunderstand
not just the pro-life movement they
misunderstand christianity in general
the big scary reveal of the moment
is that the girls are kidnapped by this
christian couple and taken to their home
and
tried to be chased down and there's a
car chase and
all to prevent the abortion and the
climax happens
when the lesbian with daddy issues walks
into the attic
and discovers pro-life yard signs
oh my god hello baby
so they have to run and then they get
chased down in a car and everything
so a few signs early on that you can
tell these filmmakers have no idea they
don't know anything about christianity
is there's a lot of catholic iconography
around the house so they're crucifixes
rather than just you know generally
protestants tend to prefer just a cross
without the body of christ on it
there are crucifixes there's a lot of
marian iconography one of the
family's uh kids is named mary but then
they kind of talk like
more evangelical protestants they behave
that way they've got more of an
evangelical aesthetic so they're just
very confused on
on that aspect of things they think that
christians would
kidnap people and uh you know drag them
out to the
their desert home for some reason they
live in the middle of nowhere in this
beautiful home
and hold them against their will of
course that uh would be
sinful and no one would do that you see
this later in the movie when they go to
the abortion clinic
and the pro-life people are screaming
and they're angry i've been outside of
planned parenthoods okay the only
screaming angry people are the
abortionists in there
and the leftist pro-abortion advocates
that the people who
i went to a major rally outside of a
planned parenthood
it was people praying the rosary very
quietly praying offering literature on
information about this just a complete
misunderstanding you until this is a
filmmaker who has never
talked to anybody at all who's pro-life
and then the third thing they
misunderstand
is most essential they misunderstand
abortion itself and they go
at one point in the movie it's just a
whole commercial for abortion
and how great it is and you'll just feel
wonderful at the end and there's nothing
to worry about
we'll draw some blood and we'll hook you
up to an iv
[Music]
then you'll sit with other women who are
waiting for surgery
now i'll pause right there pause right
there you just say you'll sit with other
women who are waiting for surgery
surgery here is the euphemism for
abortion
this whole movie is about is is about
creating a system
whereby young teenage girls can get
abortions maybe to cover up their
personal decisions that were
undertaken consensually although i
thought you know by the way we have an
age of consent for a reason
in the age of me too right we're told
that
there is that's why we have statutory
rape right as we're saying girls under a
certain age
people under a certain age do not have
the wherewithal to consent
so on the one hand they're telling us
it's all about consent on the other hand
they're saying yeah these 13 year old
girls yeah they can totally consent get
them abortions
which is by the way one of the one of
the tools most
prayed for most wished for by rapists
and all sorts of other evil people
is that you can have an abortion to get
away with any evidence of the crime
especially when the parents don't pay
attention but here
you see this age group you have a 17
year old girl you got a 75 year old
woman a 75 year old woman
probably not going to get an abortion it
continues
the anesthesiologist will place a mask
on your face and you'll be asleep in
seconds
the doctor has a wand that he'll insert
inside you and remove the fetus
you'll be in and out in under 10 minutes
[Music]
pause it there again there's a big
moment in the movie where
she's talking to this abortionist with a
young protagonist talking to the
abortionist
and the abortionist says yeah and you
can be asleep for the whole thing you
can either have local anesthetic or you
can be put completely under and be
asleep
and the girl goes oh i'd much rather be
asleep that was a little a little
revealing right because of yeah of
course you would because you know
that what's happening here is so grave
it's so morally indefensible you just
want to be knocked out for it you just
want to be totally
unconscious because if you were
conscious of what's going on you'd know
how evil it is that's what makes us
uncomfortable that's what
the bioethicist leon cass might call the
wisdom of repugnance
even if you can't reason through why
it's so awful you just know at a gut
level oh my gosh what i'm doing is so
wrong so she's got to be knocked out
and then she goes to the recovery room
now it's ten minutes it's so easy you've
got the kids going and then
you're just in the recovery room and
it'll all be wonderful you'll wake up in
the recovery room
safe and sound
[Music]
seems so wonderful gosh it seems so
relaxing so you're in the recovery room
and then
you know this is pretty invasive surgery
because you've just had a human being
your child removed from you
so you're probably there recovering for
a while it's not too nice right nope the
movie
then depicts the gal just
skipping out of the abortion clinic to
see her friend and then they go on and
go have lunch
you're alive oh they wouldn't let me see
you so i just assumed you were dead
oh no i'm fine how are you feeling
relieved
and hungry food okay yeah ravenous i'm
sure
that line you're alive is pretty
ghoulish in there right you're alive yes
i'm alive my child's not alive
but i'm alive it's so it's so
it had to be intentional as you're
leaving the abortion you say you're
alive but
the reality is you don't go skipping out
of your abortion that's that's not how
this works
totally fine right feeling right as a
daisy that's not
that's not what happens i know people
who have had abortions i suspect
you might know people who have had
abortions you might know people who have
had abortions
and you might not even know that they've
had abortions you don't walk
out of that scot-free feeling great and
clean skipping on your way to lunch
the people i know have had abortions
have deep
profound psychological trauma from it
sometimes
people have physical trauma from that
you're the case what was completely
covered up by the mainstream media of
kermit gosnell the worst serial killer
in american history
he was botching abortions in
philadelphia and killing women as a
result
so you don't always walk away from it
anyway but but even when you do
the psychological trauma doesn't go away
one thing we're told is that without
legal abortion there would be thousands
of women dying from back alley abortions
that's what happened before roe v wade
that's not true when you look at how
many people it was
fewer than 40 people died of illegal
abortions the year before roe v wade
fewer than 40 people died from
legal abortions and actually when you
when you look at the number of states
that where it was legal and illegal
you were just as likely to die from
illegal abortions from an illegal
abortion the number were very small
in any case so you wouldn't have that
sort of thing botched back alley all
these sorts of things
but you do have the trauma you do have
the psychological trauma and this
rosy propaganda is not depicting the
reality it's not predicting the
political reality it's not depicting
the religious reality it's not depicting
the scientific reality
of abortion you know i keep mentioning
it's it's about this sort of sociopathic
narcissist
gal and then her lesbian friend with
daddy issues and i i hope you don't
think that i'm
i'm using the phrase lesbian with daddy
issues in any sort of pejorative way i'm
using it in a purely descriptive way
it is a major plot point of of the movie
that this gal is a lesbian and she hates
her father and so much of this movie
comes down to i hate my father i hate my
father i hate my
these dads are bad uh which a lot of
liberalism tends to come down to
there's a scene in the movie where the
the blue-haired gal goes up and
and meets her dad because her dad ran
out on her and
her dad didn't want her in the first
place wanted wanted or aborted
and he left because the mother insisted
on having children
and the i guess the political message
there of the movie is
it would be better if unwanted children
were never born because they were killed
before they were born
but what's amazing they couldn't do it
they couldn't make it work from a
narrative perspective
so then the protagonist the blonde girl
jumps in and she says how dare you not
want this
this girl is the most amazing wonderful
special terrific girl ever and that's
the nice moment where they come back
together and reconcile in their
friendship but it totally undermines the
argument of the movie which
is that unwanted children should not be
born they should be killed in utero
because the gal the best friend who
helps
who helps the protagonist have the
abortion
she was an unwanted child so if the
logic of abortion is true
then that friendship shouldn't exist and
the girl wouldn't be able to get the
abortion anyway it totally undermines
the whole message of the movie but this
is a very poorly done movie just as a
matter of filmmaking
and it's funny if you look on rotten
tomatoes critics score pretty high
audience score pretty low if you look at
unplanned you know the pro-life movie
critics score very low audience score
pretty high that's the way it goes
there's a real perversity to anyone who
would green light this
this movie and put it on hbo if for no
other reason that it's just a crappy
movie but
but also because of of its just heinous
heinous message
there's a real perversity to that the
perversity is the elites it's the
gatekeepers it's the people who are
producing the movies
distributing them and reviewing them
then when you look at the audience you
say what are people seeing i think
they're seeing the reality up much much
better
than the artists who are supposedly
showing us this vision of the world well
it's a vision that's perverse and it's
wrong and i don't recommend
you go see it